a rescue drill on the River Tees the
cleveland fire brigade are called out
frequently by people stranded on boats
or in trouble in the water time is
critical but the River Tees is more than
a hundred and thirty five kilometers
long and when a call comes in it's not
always clear where the people are who
need rescuing or fire control estimate
if that a mobile phone on them and who
doesn't know it is literally asked them
can you just please download this up and
tell us what the three words say those
three words identified an area on the
River Tees behind me called Horseshoe
Bend so that meant from time of call
download in the app to rescue was about
the 11 minutes and not that that is
fantastic what three words is a free app
on your phone the company is divided up
the globe into three meter squares each
specific location is then given three
random words
purple Nightingale jumping could be the
front door of your house it's an updated
longitude and latitude system for a
voice-activated world and it's in 40
languages they make money by licensing
the technology to companies like
delivery services or car manufacturers
the idea came out of a musician's
frustration chris sheldricks spent hours
lugging guitars amplifiers microphones
around festivals searching for the right
stage or entry gate we've written a
mathematical algorithm which actually
distributes the three word addresses
across the world and that then is
replicated in every new language that we
bring up we literally cover the whole
world even the North Pole South Pole the
oceans there is a three word address for
everywhere there are lots of places that
are hard to pinpoint if you want to meet
a friend at a beach or out in the remote
desert it's not so easy Mongolian nomads
by their very nature don't stay in one
place so they need to update tourists
who come to experience tent life of the
57 trillion squares I'm a dated shark
edgy which is great if I want to meet a
friend or get a delivery but it's not
all about convenience if I were to get
hopelessly lost
or fall and break my leg it could be
life-saving more than 80 emergency
services in the UK now use what three
words they've been able to find people
trapped in their cars lost hikers and
some drifting in the River Tees Jessica
Baldwin al-jazeera Pembury England